moken say season 1 was
like oh God it's so beautiful oh God
it's so Hy oh God bre and now season 2
was like all right let's see where
rudius is getting up to now how's it
going my name is Otis never soft again
and recently I was diagnosed with
erectile
dysfunction oh he ain't getting up to
anything are you waiting to receive my
limp penis when you've watched anime for
a long enough time you start to think
you've seen it all the same tropes the
same plot developments it starts to
become rare for a series to explore
something you haven't seen some
iteration before so col me surprised
when we show Kensa returns coming off
the back of introducing one of the most
immersive worlds and JRE defining
stories in isaka to go hey want to see
what happens when the hero can't get his
PP hard doesn't work we've had some
Banger anime this year exploring some
pretty unique topics oino highlighting
the darkest sides of the entertainment
industry hell's Paradise introducing us
to a beautiful but deadly world z 100
giving us the joyous fantasy every wage
slave needs mashal Heavenly delusion I'm
about to try and convince you all that a
guy attempting to get a hard on for 12
episodes stops all that but before that
a word from today's sponsor guys did you
know that one out of 10 men are likely
to suffer from erectile dysfunction over
the course of their lives you may feel
like there's nowhere to turn to but
thanks to today's sponsor oin chinense
bonerless reincarnation that's a thing
of the
past God I wish that were actually real
all right let's do the real sponsor Ron
today's actual sponsor guys if you've
been on YouTube before you've probably
heard of rayon but did you know that
this year they are turning 6 years old
that's right 6 years old and in that
time raycon has really made a name for
themselves in the premium audio space I
mean just this year they've expanded
their entire business to raycon home and
raycon power Tech so there is a lot to
celebrate and to thank everyone who's
shown the support in the last six years
they are having a massive sale right now
with 20% off everything in their site
with some products being up to 40% off
this is the perfect time to get get
yourself some products that made raycon
so well known like their everyday
earbuds their everyday earbuds are known
for delivering high quality audio and
thoughtful features like a 32-hour
battery life and a perfect inair fit for
all day wear and Lasting Comfort all
this for half the price of other premium
Brands which is the reason they've
racked up over 78,000 f-star reviews
genuinely I've been using the rayon
everyday earbuds since they first
sponsored me because I've not found
another pair of earbuds that are as
convenient and as small as the rayon
earbuds these are just like the perfect
ear bus when you're like on the go or
doing a quick casual workout and you
just need something small and convenient
to carry around without taking too much
pocket space so if you're just looking
for earbuds that are really convenient
and won't break your bank I actually
highly recommend you getting yourself a
pair and now's the best time with the
biggest sale of the Year going on now
just click that link in the description
or go to bon.com Gig and use code
birthday to get 20 to 40% off sitewide
Happy 6th anniversary to rayon and with
that said back to the video 2 years ago
Michelle kensei introduced us to one of
the most immersive work worlds I've ever
seen in anime it was a beautiful
carefully crafted Place rich with law
and history that was full of life this
wasn't just an isekai by name it gave us
a new world you felt you could truly get
transported to complimented with
character writing that filled the place
up with people that felt as alive as its
world did seeing Rudy's Journey Through
the world truly felt like you were going
on an adventure with him getting swept
up in the places he went to and the
people he encountered so much so that
when that part of the journey came to an
end you felt as empty as he did leaving
us off with him learning some harsh
lessons as he starts his next phase of
life it was a magical journey so season
2 had some big shoes to live up to what
Adventures was Rudy going to go on now
what new places were we going to visit
what new world shattering developments
were we going to see ah let's make his
dick not work yes if you haven't heard
the writer made the brave decision to
make Rudy dealing with erectile
dysfunction a sizable plot thread to the
entire season and I've actually seen
people pretty split about it so I'm here
to argue that this Arc not only
encapsulates everything that Mich Kent
says about but why memes aside I still
enjoyed the hell out of
it here I am I've reached a point in my
career where I'm somehow arguing for
erectile dysfunction I think this my
anime list review sums it up pretty well
if you're too busy to read the whole
summary here are two points for my
review bad animation bad Arc 7 out of 10
what now granted I know going to my
anime list for serious reviews is like
asking crypto Bros for financial advice
but these are pretty much the sentiments
I've seen floating around so let's
tackle this first point bad animation M
kensei season 1 was an absolute
animation masterclass in almost every
department and there was a lot of fears
from fans going into the season because
some of the key staff members in charge
of making it look this good was moving
on to other projects and to be fair it
is a slight downgrade it isn't polished
to the point of being the cinema quality
Pierce of resistance the first season
was but B congratulations we've
downgraded from The Last of Us remake on
PlayStation 5 to The Last of Us on
PlayStation 4 we might have experienced
a new season of anime that's felt like
it's had a dropping quality before but
if this is bad Animation Seven Deadly
Sins fans are on godamn suicide watch if
they aren't already considering the
production of this took half the time
and we didn't have to wait three more
years in between Seasons I am more than
happy if this is going to be the quality
going forward because Mishu tensei was
never just about the amazing animation
which brings me to the next Point bad
Arc to this topic I like to talk about
how to fix nip mode all right this one
might take a little longer obvious PP
memes aside I think a big turnoff people
have had is that there just weren't a
lot of major developments this was a
season that really slows things down and
takes some time to explore its own
characters there are some new
interesting law drops that set things up
for future events but like Vinland Saga
earlier this year the pacing crawled to
a standstill in favor of Rudy living his
life as a young adult now and being more
flaccid than edus waking up in an
orphanage but while villain Saga already
proved that you can completely change
things up and turn into a slow paced
character drama and people can still
come out of it acknowledging that it's a
godamn masterpiece so what's the
difference well thorin's character Arc
never led to
[Music]
this but I would argue that the slower
paced approach to storytelling has
always been what sets this show apart
from everything else Mich show can say
doesn't have the cool philosophical
lines or a main character you want to go
off and brag about but what it does have
is a story that feels so innately real
it's almost uncanny events and time
progression play out in a similar pace
you'd expect them to in life episode by
episode you don't think much happens but
you know how if you see someone every
day you don't really notice any change
with them and then one day you look back
to a picture of what they looked like 5
years ago and it's like what what when
the [__] did Rudy become a ripped
teenager characters react and treat each
other like people real people every
single person regardless of if they give
you a 100 lines or two give you a sense
that they're on their own personal
Journey as meaningful as Rudy's is it's
this commitment to realism that makes
makes it such a joy just to be in this
world meaning even the smallest
developments or character actions hold
far more weight than they usually would
what would need to happen in a man's
life to learn how to forgive what
happens when you're so hung up on an ex
that even your dick stops listening to
you it's embarrassing it's awkward it
certainly isn't cool but that's exactly
why it seemed so oddly realistic in a
way few shows could get away with
because it was so on point for a person
like Rudy rudius has certainly been a
divisive character for anyone watching
the show he's done many things to turn a
lot of people off which very much
continues all the way through to the
second season so if you're one of those
people that find it morally
reprehensible seeing a guy act like this
and you can't fully invest yourself when
this guy is meant to be the protagonist
of the story understandable have a nice
day season 2 is not going to change your
mind Rudy is perverted he's weird he's
downright creepy but let's be real do
you really think that a previously shut
in hintai addicted virgin transported to
a fantasy world without the same moral
standards and repercussions of our
modern world is going to act any
different here's what happens when a
horny weeb gives into to all their
intrusive thoughts you might not keep
anyone like Rudy around you but you've
probably encountered someone that's come
a bit too uncomfortably close to walking
down his path which is why to me he
seems just as real as the characters
around him this is the ark where we get
to see him deal with depression from
something that has nothing to do with
his previous life so what Earth
shattering thing could be affecting him
bullying the gruesome death of a loved
one nope girlfriend troubles oh cheer up
mate there's plenty of fish in the sea
it seems trivial but that's why I
respect the decision to spend a seismo
amount of time exploring it we forget
that even though he was an adult in his
previous life just how emotionally
immature He Is We often like to dismiss
events that happened in our young years
as dumb teenage ANS that we've grown
past but [__] man so much of that stuff
sticks with you even if you don't
remember it maybe your parents said some
offhand comment that one time or a
teacher shouted at you for something you
did or you know a crush said something
mean to you in your most vulnerable
moment don't go getting the wrong idea I
only came up here cuz I felt obligated
you what it's moments like these that
can shape the way you act going into
adulthood and you probably don't even
realize how much you internalized it
until it's way too late and you can see
this through every phase of Rudy's
struggle with the scars he's carried on
from not just his previous life but the
one he has now as well guys in our most
loneliest and desperate moments we'd
like to think that we're [__] Ryan
goling in our Mind's Eye sexually
brooding by ourselves in a dark corner
but let's be honest we're probably
closer to Rudy in our darkest times at
first he just keeps himself and just
deals with it finds other things to
distract him gets called out doesn't say
anything eventually lashes out tries to
forget his frustrations with a girl
makes things worse alienates the people
around him before erupting in the most
toxic and self-destructive way possible
you're the worst I never want to see
your face
[Music]
again this is the type of [__] people
spend years working through can you
hasten that development for a fictional
story like this sure if you want the
instant gratification of seeing someone
overcome their internal issues but like
life there is no easy way to go about
this you can tell me that time has
passed but it's a whole other thing to
make me feel the time and effort it
takes to get through the smallest bit of
your trauma this is the commitment Mich
kensei makes that few series are willing
to do when you see character growth in
the story you normally see this person
with some kind of flaw and through a
character Arc they real realiz this flaw
overcome it grow as a character and it
never becomes an issue again that
particular character Arc has now come to
an end and you know it's great it's
satisfying it's by the book good
storytelling but in reality life isn't
always as smooth as fiction is your mate
doesn't give you a single monologue one
day and then instantly all the bad
things you suddenly realize you want to
change about yourself are immediately
fixed even if you recognize that you
want to change it takes time it takes
effort it takes commitment people try
get better relapse into bad habits try
again spiral even further down climb
back up fall back down again years can
pass and some people might never find
that drive to keep trying again life
isn't always a straight linear upshot of
a journey and that's what makes Rudy's
story so captivating it takes the time
to show you every aspect of his life
Journey not just the parts where he
takes a positive step some episodes he
takes one step forward some he takes
three steps back there'll be a four
episode stint where he makes no progress
and doesn't grow as a human being at all
but it has enough faith in you to stick
with it cuz it wants you to be here for
the long game M say's newest Arc might
not have the world shaking plot
developments or the high intensity
action scenes but it made me realize
what made the series truly special and
why the source material so godamn long
this is someone's life story and it
fully commits to showing you the
entirety of it through every up and down
through the fast years and the slow
years like life itself and because of
that it feels so intimately realistic
you forget that this is a fictional
story set in a madeup world at some
point it felt like I was watching a real
biography about a person that really
existed sometimes I thought it had more
in common with an episode of Terrace
House that just happened to be set in
another world than your typical fantasy
story that's the immersive power this
Series has the only series I've ever
encountered that can simultaneously drop
my jaw to the floor at a near-death
experience while also making me feel
genuine emotional gratification at the
sight of a bro popping a boner by the
end of this Arc Rudy still might not be
a good person he might not be the
protagonist that deserves our cheers
just yet but you know what it still
feels good to see a guy get even the
smallest W in their lives when they
worked hard to get it and that ladies
and gentlemen is why erectile
dysfunction is the greatest thing to
happen to storytelling in the history of
isekai Sir this is a
Wendy's oh being
hard could open a lot of doors for
you proven your
hard can open a lot of
doors for me it's hard to go to work
with a bone
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month to Alpha
Sigma author Curtis Xin basil
dysfunctional degenerate iido lavados
flabber walki makaka 12315 hay patchet
Pony Stark water gist VT and everyone
else my patreon for helping to support
me for this month and making this video
possible yes guys as you can see I'm
finally back in Japan and it looks like
this time I'm actually going to be
staying here for a reasonable amount of
time no more traveling for a while thank
God so aside from the stuff I'm doing on
this channel I'm probably going to pick
up streaming again so you can catch me
at twitch.tv/ gig whenever I have time
to stream or you can catch my highlights
Channel or vods Channel if you want to
watch it on YouTube anyway though that's
been it for me for today I've been gig
and I'll see you all next time